on liberia's providence island an
african-american is in search of her
past laura pritchard from michigan is
stepping in the ruins of the first home
built by freed american slaves brought
to africa some 200 years ago it's on
providence island that they founded the
republic of liberia providence island
feels like liberty providence island
feels like healing
um providence highland feels like joy
and anticipation and that providence
island means it's a place where i can
remove i can take the chains from my
neck
i can shake the dust from my feet and i
can start new
that's what i feel
[Music]
in the country's oldest church the young
gathered to celebrate thanksgiving a
tradition brought by the free slaves
supported by the american colonization
society the founding settlers became the
country's elite and they kept many
african natives in servitude
transforming their traditions culture
and architecture
according to the truth and
reconciliation commission this helped
fuel liberia's civil wars a quarter of a
million people died during the two
decade-long conflicts
we're in downtown monrovia from where
during the civil war snipers would shoot
at people and it's in this neighborhood
that yet again a hundred-year-old
building is being torn down to make way
for new apartment blocks now for some
this is liberia moving away from its
past looking towards the future for
others preserving these old buildings is
an essential act of remembrance of
liberia's troubled and divided past
but this is magnificent and they look so
much alike
a shack that the owner richard tolbert
wants to tear down but architect joseph
jones sees history worth preserving
you cannot forget about your past
we will warn the kids the the the kids
who are studying architecture to
understand
how
houses were built in liberia before and
why
almost all of the free slaves came from
america's southern state of south
carolina the southerners came here
trying to
emulate american culture
they brought american culture back to
liberia their intentions were not to be
africans
libera's history does not start with the
arrival of african americans jones
believes some of the street names should
reference the nation's 17 indigenous
groups an effort to be made to preserve
the diverse architectural history of the
country as an increasing number of
african-americans make liberia their
home laura pritchard believes there's so
much to learn from the past
in order to build a better future for
all librarians
nicholas hawk al-jazeera providence
island liberia